we've got some breaking news now and I
want to get the latest with Zena holiday
in Beirut so as we said at the top of
the bulletin Zana the Israeli Army is
targeting an open area in the vicinity
of a Border Town of Lebanon what more
are you hearing about this incident
yes yet another
cross-border fire incident along this uh
this volatile border the Israeli Army
saying that it is shelling areas
um close to the town of kharshuba in
response to rockets that were fired from
Southern Lebanon towards Israel this
morning now earlier there were reports
that Rockets were fired from Lebanon
towards Israel but there was no
confirmation
from the Israelis at the time they said
that a mine had had exploded now this
incident comes amid the backdrop of
really a very tense tense situation in
recent in recent weeks neither side
really has an interest in in provoking a
major war but we have seen uh
cross-border fire
um in in recent weeks and months now
what what is happening is that Israel
has been working along the border
engineering work trying to erect a new
fence a new border wall and more often
than not they seem to be Crossing into
Lebanese territory and now the Lebanese
group Hezbollah which has fought with
Israel in the past is saying that Israel
has taken over quote Lebanese land in
the town of khajar now this border there
are certain points along this 130
kilometer border which remained disputed
so a very tense situation we've seen
cross-border fire in the past the
situation is usually contained in in
just a few hours but this time it comes
really amid a backdrop of several
incidents that that is that is Raising
um raising the alarm
Zain and we're having a look at having a
look now at some of the vision from the
area at that border it doesn't look like
it's inhabited or there doesn't seem to
be many people that live in that area
can you describe the region where this
is happening and whether or not that
there's been any comment from the
Lebanese Army or the United Nations
peacekeeping force in southern Lebanon
well yeah so far no comment from the
Japanese Army I just got off the phone
with the United Nations they are the
peacekeeping force which is supposed to
which is deployed in the Border region
to reduce pensions uh they're still
looking into the incidents this morning
uh but but like you said like I said
earlier neither side really has an
interest in provoking a major war and
that's why when Rockets are fired from
Southern Lebanon towards Israel or when
Israel shells areas of Lebanon they
choose the open territory they choose to
avoid casualties
um a major war really will be
destructive for both for both sides
um so the you know this comes amid the
backdrop of a wider usually we see these
that the tension along the border when
when two things are happening one when
when there's tension either in Gaza the
West Bank uh Hezbollah has always said
that Israel is facing uh you know one
front one front uh from from more than
the equation of you unifying the front
if you like between all the players of
quote the resistance axis so it usually
is a political message and escalation
also comes when
um when there are Israeli uh airstrikes
targeting Iranian Targets in neighboring
Syria so when you have these escalation
on other fronts we do see tension flare
along the Lebanon Israel border this is
likely to be contained maybe for now but
it is something to watch in the hours
and days to come in light against the
backdrop of of tensions along the border
um in in Lebanon zaina what are some of
the international ramifications of this
what are we likely to see as a result of
this uh shelling or cross-border rocket
launches
we are going to see a
intense diplomatic contacts behind the
scenes to reduce tensions a major war
will serve no side at this point in time
Israel knows it is you know it is facing
an enemy Hezbollah which has you know
grown its Arsenal since their last war
in 2006. we know that Hezbollah has
position guided missiles and we know
that they can hit and target areas deep
inside Israel but we also know that
Israel can carry out massive airstrikes
um you know destroying large areas of
the country so this has happened in the
past so neither side it is no no size
interest we are going to see a lot of
behind the scenes diplomatic activity
but the bottom line is this Israel Steve
has the law as an extension of Iran and
Hezbollah is an ally of Iran it doesn't
shy away from that fact and it has made
that clear on on in more than one on
more than one occasion and it's not just
that I mean the the head of Allah has
made it clear that Hezbollah has
established publish this equation if you
like and they call it the unifying of of
fronts you know whether
um Israel you know launches attacks
against Palestinians Lebanese syrians
all the different uh players of the
so-called resistance axis will come
together so Israel will be facing
um you know response from multiple
multiple fronts so this also has a
regional Dimension there's no doubt
about this
um and also you have Hezbollah showing
it's it's you know to the Lebanese
people because it has gained a lot of
enemies and domestic enemies because
it's it's decision to remain armed it
wants to legitimize
um why it continues uh to to be armed in
this country as because of Israel and
the provocative acts along the border so
we are going to see a lot of diplomatic
activity to try to reduce pensions the
United Nations will be calling both
sides an urging restraint but if there
is a political will to um to to escalate
to ask to escalate the tensions even
further it's unlikely the United Nations
can stand and can stop that from
happening all right Zena horos thanks so
much for breaking you know down for us
zaina Hodder in Beirut let's go to Imran
Khan who joins us from West Jerusalem
hello there Imran what can we make of
the timing of these rocket launches
particularly given what's happened in
Janine at the start of the week and how
Hezbollah has expressed support for the
Palestinian cause during that Israeli
operation
I mean expressing support for a
particular cause and actually firing
Rockets are two very different things as
my colleagues and the butler is pointing
out
um neither side has
um any interest in uh escalation and
taking this further but there was an
awful lot of confusion uh initially when
uh this rocket was fired very early in
the morning we heard that a rocket had
been fired up from that area uh and but
then almost immediately there was a
denial from an Israeli Army Source on
Israeli Army Radio saying actually know
the explosions were actually happened in
a Minefield
um and that Rockets weren't fired
however the Israeli Army then uh
clarified saying that they uh following
the report of an explosion near the town
of goza soldiers arrived at the scene
and it was revealed that a launch was
carried out from Lebanese territory
which exploded uh adjacent to the Border
in Israeli territory now in response uh
the Israeli Army is currently striking
the area from which the launch was
carried out
they are effectively striking an empty
field
um now when we've seen in the past for
example in Gaza Rockets being fired or
we've seen them being fired from
elsewhere it's normally that kind of
place that they fired them from uh
because they can set up very quickly
they can leave very quickly but this is
a tactic that we have seen before now no
one's claimed responsibility for it so
far it's likely uh according to Israeli
media forces that there have been about
15 artillery strikes
um on that area
without a response
um you have to ask yourself what are
they actually eating if these uh these
rockets that we've seen in the past
second Gaza you know they're very small
they're very portable the guys put them
up and then they leave very quickly
um so it's more likely that this is
basically a show of force it's a
response uh it's a proportional response
into uh in terms of the kind of rockets
that were fired or rocket that was fired
from Lebanese territory so it's likely
that this will be it it won't escalate
any further however
um you know if both sides will it if one
side wants to escalate then like my
colleague zaina said
there's really nothing International
Community or the United Nations can do
about it Imran I know it's very early
days yet but has there been any response
from the Israeli army or any official
word from Israeli officials about what's
unfolding
uh no other than the statement that I
just told you about which uh you know
basically says that they went down to
the site
um they confirmed that it was a rocket
launch and then
um they have basically uh started
launching artillery Strokes on the area
that's all we're hearing right now it's
all we're likely to hear I don't know if
this is the kind of thing uh the Israeli
security establishment will begin to
comment on further there may well be
leaks to local media suggesting uh
giving a culprit as it were
um maybe blaming Hezbollah for this baby
blaming another local group that acts
within the area but there are awful a
lot of attentions on that border you
know Israel's long been accused of
mounting illegal excursions
um into Lebanese territory and that's
it's always been a flash point but like
you say the timing is interesting it
comes after the Janine cab raid which is
the largest raid that's taken place
um uh in nearly 20 years uh it also
comes as the Israeli security
establishment have said that the Janine
raid is a blueprint for further raids uh
not just within the occupied West Bank
but other places as well uh so it could
well be just a message
um no one's claimed responsibility for
this right now but that may change in
the coming hours it certainly might all
right thanks so much for bringing us up
to speed Imran Khan in West Jerusalem
and just repeating that breaking news
out of Israel and Lebanon the Israeli
Army is targeting an open area in the
vicinity of a Lebanese Border Town they
say it's in response to an explosion we
have correspondence in Lebanon and as we
just heard from Imran Khan we have him
in Western Jerusalem so we'll bring you
more information as it comes to hand